you swim with dolphins well I've taken
up the hobby of scuba diving which I
really really enjoy and some went down
I've been shark diving she was kind of
amazing
I had a real close encounter with a
shark really although it wasn't it was
about six feet eight people well it
wasn't the type of fish
I was near fish
[Music]
[Applause]
ooh I need for you all of your stories
rules for swimming with dolphins with
dolphins I heard that you're not
supposed to touch a dolphin unless they
come to you and offer themselves for a
rub oh if they don't because dolphins
mate for life and if you touch one of
them the other one can smell your your
touch on them and they think that
they've cheated on them and then that
you can break up a dolphin marriage tag
is true that is fact I know I'm gonna
have to phone up SeaWorld directly I've
been bad ones blow
she's had a dolphin orgy if that's the
case broken up a few dolphin marriage I
went to Cuba and I sort of was in a
situation where they were like Jonah
swimming with dolphins and they actually
taught me how to sort of be lifted up on
the nose of two dolphins with a foot on
each on these now if you think she's
making somebody filmed it that's a good
stuff got the footage no I was near a
fish one that's not nice I'm willing to
this it's not great to begin with I'll
give you that it does look like the run
in the water now watch it
[Applause]
you've got any footage of you near that
fish
[Music]